morning Millennials welcome back to the
morning to us we are back live in studio
today to finish off this dazzling week
I just feel dazzled this week has just
been a lot of shuckin and jivin I'm
gonna take the back I don't feel dazzle
honestly I feel frazzled I feel like a
Miss Frizzle I can't believe it's Friday
and I didn't realize it was Friday until
I saw snitch's Instagram story that it's
me music Friday like that is shocking no
not only is it shocking it's also like
doesn't feel like Friday because I got
to work this weekend so it's like never
ends yeah it's been a crazy week
crazy week doesn't end up going to
Baltimore tonight sorry it sold out
tomorrow night I'm gonna be in Silver
Spring in between Baltimore and Maryland
oh no Baltimore and DC so if you're in
the area come through it's lit that'll
be fun yeah that's so much fun anyways
I'm sick and tired but I'm also sick so
if you hear me sniffling or sneezing I'm
so sorry in a band you know what I
always think of when someone says sick
and tired I'm sick and tired of being
sick and tired
was it from I don't know it's just I am
sick and tired of being sick but really
it's not a saying it's Irma moving I'm
sick and tired of being sick and tired
look I can catch up on my Z's this
weekend speaking of these yesterday was
my man's birthday do you like my
Instagram caption they're saying that
this is from a civil rights activist but
it's much definitely a movie
no but mean it's a civil rights activist
I'm sure he or she was sick and tired of
being sick and tired
monster-in-law that sounds right Jane
Fonda always complaining did you see
mainstream caption um yes I I did let's
[ __ ] around and make make baby number
two very clever very clever very very
timely and topical I was just on one the
past two days I think it's just the the
tiredness it's like your man made out
with Joe and eventually we will stop
talking about how tired we are but not
before we delivered the fast we're going
right into it no I just thought it was a
good segue time to talk about it okay so
thanks for ruining my perfect sense too
tired
thank you can only say once no I mean
how many times are they gonna play we
literally I said it multiple times but
like thank you for it
I can't thank you enough for ruining my
perfect moment now you know how feels
terribly interrupting cow Moos call me a
cow it's a saying oh sure interrupting
cow Baidu
you're a [ __ ] it's just race that's
actually a great light comeback right
you know it's a baby saying these is a
during civil-rights you don't know that
famous saying that afraid you never hurt
Wow
you should really get a cousin depends
actually so funny but Wow I remember my
first time learning about history so
yeah it's just been like a crazy meet
Jackie and I went to the Billboard Music
Awards which was honestly a roller
coaster of emotions but it was it was so
cool and a lot of you were wondering
like what happened to us cuz like there
was a little bit of John feel like
Jackie I just like waltz onto the red
carpet like as if it was put down and
laid down for us and we didn't know
there was like just all this stuff you
had to do like protocol and literally
we're like ready to take we're getting
our photo taken like I start on your ad
I was like hey girl I was acting like
literally was my Bobbitt's and we did
get a couple foot of snap to vesemir
making our way down the carpet and
they're like show us your wristbands and
we wouldn't put them on cuz two months
we were spending so he opened our purse
I was like my wrist fans in here so we
showed them and they literally start
whispering each other he was like oh
okay I see come with me so we're like oh
we're going like oh this is weird and he
literally dropped us on the curb like he
might as well have manhandled me like
grabbed my arm like he was he was a
wrist snap yeah we were like excuse me
we have a podcast called the morning
totes it was horrifying
because yeah and just plucked us to the
curb but then we realized we have the
wrong wristbands we to go get the right
ones it was like so traumatic and it
ended up being better because when we by
the time we got to the carpet after all
the drama I was like when the cool
people came like yeah we were walking
right next to LMA uh-huh and by the way
Gemma's hair name I always think lmao of
course we're supposed to think I know
but her name is Ella Mae yeah but I'm
just like ayo I'm like LM a oh did blow
them like all the other sub Ernie's who
really show up like as the party
starting not with you know the digital
influencers an hour and half before
which was our calls so you know what it
ended up working out I got to meet Diplo
and him
and diem in quite a bit ever since his
iconic research-based set at at
stagecoach and I was just telling him
like how I thought he did such a great
job and on the red carpet I was I by the
way like I'm Claudia like we've been GI
me and he was like he was you don't
expect someone like who's just like all
dressed up like that to be so nice and
he was like he was just like a guy he's
like thank you so much for being so nice
about my set and I was like thank you
thank you for the work that you put it
it was just honestly artists respecting
artists the whole night was about
artists respecting artists well recap
the show that is our first story but
it's just a little more carpet news we
also saw this is yours Foster of course
it's just it was nice to see a couple
sisters never failed to make us look
short
oh and that also got a picture it's like
I truly hated how I was remember we were
talking about like should we get new
sprays hands in our legs because we shut
up okay
and I remember saying oh the worst thing
that happens to be the two pale but it's
better than looking to Orange oh it's
not oh I totally disagreed with you when
you know what I should have went against
my against my gut no no I'm sorry
I should have went with my gut I always
listen to you because you're a genius
most of the time no I'm a you were run
by the spray tans I couldn't believe
that like we could look so pale you want
to know what else was outside less than
a week after getting a spray - yeah most
of red carpets like we'll have some sort
of lighting but we were outside so it
was just us and God and God did not
smile he was laughing at us yeah man
plans God laughs okay God was laughing
at our plans and our pal leg oh my god
everything was so pale and like honestly
the paleness of my legs and just like my
entire body wasn't even my biggest
concern it's like I spent literally an
hour to be my makeup where did it go and
as I'm scrubbing off my makeup before
the flight I'm like damn I'm wearing a
lot of makeup but the pictures couldn't
tell you that
no also I think the backdrop of the red
carpet being black didn't help us either
oh the contractor time tried that's a
good call but anyways we got our photo
taken it was fun we were actually our
asses a great seats to the actual
theater
mhm oh um we saw Taylor Swift perform we
saw halti performance our Khalid perform
so that's our first story okay segue
season two the Fast Five story is that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
music awards were at the MGM and Las
Vegas hosted by Kelly Clarkson who's a
precious gem of a woman who's next to us
for a second then got her appendix for
me yes she was having appendicitis
during the show she was in so much pain
hopped on a plane right after got her
pendeks out the next morning what a
[ __ ] pro what a professional she was
so good her opener was so good and it's
really crazy when you watch something on
TV you think that everything is just
like so big but then like when we were
there it just it's people talking in the
audience and there happens to be a
camera standing right there yeah and I
hadn't been to the VMAs before and the
VMAs are super made-for-tv like people's
and microphones aren't even I'm like I
literally left halfway through I'm like
this sucks but the Billboard Music
Awards I still left halfway through it
but I was enjoying the first half yeah
we'd to make a flight but it was like
the microphones were on they had big
screens if you couldn't see it was
really like a show that was televised a
great concert yeah so many of the
performers were great Taylor Swift
really just you know threw up the
rainbow and it was it was so I wanted to
guarantee in a second but second thing I
want to talk about is the ariana grande
performance like the arena was lit up
and we were like let's [ __ ] go and
that was the last thing we were gonna
watch before we headed to the airport
and literally like there was nothing on
stage and I was so confused we're
standing up for Madonna and maluma and
we were like Ari though and it was just
a line from her concept they played it
on the screens
and she loves me I'm gonna be sick come
she did say apparently in her show we
didn't even say for the whole thing that
she's like called out Vancouver like
Vancouver show it was just so weird that
they truly tried to pass it off like it
was live why you lie and they've done it
before I've seen ed Sheeran performed
literally from the corner of an Irish
pub like the way people standing around
and they didn't pretend it was a second
at least that's clear get the tension
they're not there but it really everyone
at home thought that ariana everyone in
the video - no but when you watch on TV
until people saw her story it's like
they thought they still thought that she
was there a nice that's so misleading
why you lyin I would love to hear your
thoughts on this marching band saga
because Taylor Swift used drums from a
marching band they were all dressed up
in marching band outfits for her
performance and a lot of people are
pressed as [ __ ] and should straight up
copy Beyonce when I'm really feeling
pressed because credit Stefani is not
getting her rightful dude like if we're
gonna move out Nick Cannon
we're gonna click so true if we're gonna
claim ownership on drums which I don't
think you can they've been a part of
music I mean every part of Game of
Thrones are part of every battle
if we're gonna say history if you if you
want to claim ownership off of drums
that I'm really sorry
it belongs to Gwen Stefani I'm sorry it
belongs no it belongs to East Rutherford
High School totally
I have no time for this sort of people
on each other that's exactly what it is
and it's like I'm someone who's always
pitting women against each other just
cuz I think it's time even you need it I
draw the line like are you kidding and
maybe I only draw the line because it's
teller and I love her but like Beyonce
fans are being and they're taking it so
far on Twitter like saying such mean
things and I'm really not here for it
people have been coming for Taylor this
week like left right and [ __ ] center
and you know what I can't believe it
like all this girl's trying to do is put
on a show that's like happy and lame and
like smelly you fun I just like make
people embrace their individuality and
here she is people are saying that she's
embracing colonization's
history history again I'm just I'm still
not sure it's one big history I'm you
know what I follow Saint hoaxes and I
just love I don't know if it's her or
them like I just think they have a the
perfect way to comment on what's going
on in the world and it's just nine times
out of ten they know it but they did
something so mean like about Taylor like
Beyonce and you know what I'm really not
here for it I guess I only see it when
you repost it yeah exactly
no and I'd love to comment I said
justice for Gwen Stefani hos I don't
believe in claiming ownership of a
musical instrument but if we're going to
then the rights belong to you the
trademark is is in Gwen Stefani's name
who she license from Nick Cannon and
remind actually what you think you first
eyeliner right now but it'll probably
take us way too long yeah or bananas um
I had seen some headlines regarding this
rift and I just I paid it no mind
because that's it's like you guys are
cottage cheese and if you want if you
want the people who like try and say
that Taylor has nothing I'm Beyonce like
maybe you in some like realms do you
have an argument for sure but like
things like this are diminishing your
argument because this is so far fed
right and like what was so frustrating
about this whole thing it was like a
couple people on Twitter like half
joking about like drums and literally
like Cosmo People magazine that ran with
it and maybe the legitimate news story
I'm like that's fake news it's fake
that's always a thing like
and people feel this way they quote
three tweets oh right and then it's also
definitely what you send this it's
exactly what you said was gonna happen
with Kylie she's ready for maybe number
did you know did you know the Jackie O
problems is also ready for baby do you
know that Jackie O problems is future
what sorta psychic second yeah hold it
Oh totally [ __ ] out here you plain
okay so any more thoughts about the show
oh I'm sorry if anyone's gonna claim
ownership of over marching drums it's
the Olympics they always have marching
drums no it's it's [ __ ] Game of
Thrones total it's the North totally
it's the Stannis Baratheon on the ships
at the Battle of the Blackwater is there
anything else I wanted to discuss from
the red carpet um no we're from the show
from the show I thought it was a jolly
good show I loved it it was in Vegas
like what a good time I'm like if I had
been in any other frame of mind like not
coming off of treacherous days in Palm
Springs in LA I might have thrown down
at the after-party with Diplo because it
was at our hotel yeah and you know what
I might've been doing to stage liked
working with Halsey and we had there
Spence
yes that's only response he actually had
but no it was really fun it inspired me
to do my 20 how was my journey
huh we do what's a mine you're 20 you're
turning 25 what yeah I figured out last
night that I was 26 and Zach and they
were talking about it and I was actually
glad I thought I was 27 I don't really
think I try not to think about how old
am I swear on my life I thought I was
really doing you once were that's so
true
Wow part of you is too I gotta throw
down I was gonna make it like a nothing
birthday but it's 25 quarter of a
century we're gonna bake we are going to
Vegas
and I wanted like do it up and I already
have plans I'm going to sing the
national anthem at the Las Vegas
aviators game for sure a song about the
first morning to us take over we've been
meaning to do it like but now we've
never been in Vegas now summer weekend
of July 10th I'm doing that I want to be
at every [ __ ] beach party night club
dinner like hit me up for free stuff
like I'm [ __ ] throwing down I want a
jet I'm chartering a jet I can't wait
I'll be in the business charter uh maybe
maybe with our points Oh honest Brian
yeah okay so next story isn't loading
but I know it by heart because sophie
Turner and Jojo
got married in Las Vegas after Beebe
Emmys in what is the most epic wedding
of all time I couldn't have him around
cos top mine top Meagan Marcos and not
that that one was hard yeah but um oh my
goodness oh how fun did that look and so
I actually read today so the their reps
did confirm that it was real because
when I was happening people only knew
that it was happening because Diplo was
live-streaming it another reason why I'm
just like newly obsessed with DES newly
obsessed with Diplo I just started
following him in like every caption on
every single of his post is [ __ ]
premium it's hilarious and it's like is
he the best the greatest comedian of our
time 100% and him doing an Instagram
story from Taylor's his performance
being like oh my god he's gonna be our
new drummer and he was like Taylor told
these guys to [ __ ] beat these drums
until they're dead that's the real story
no he's your ever Abby is so funny so he
was the only one live-streaming any
people I thought it was a joke because
people like fake get married in Vegas
it's like not real you never know if
it's like an actual marriage and ended
up being true their reps ended up
confirming it but what people aren't
saying which is super important is that
they're still planning on getting
married in Europe this summer but for
legal reasons I assume they're gonna
live in America they had to get their
certificate or actually get married in
the US legally in the US before they do
it
in Europe this summer so so wedding is
gonna be so [ __ ] glam like I just
could imagine it's like all like the
Nick and Priyanka stuff except it's not
like generated media and generated
interest from the public it's like we're
dying like - no no totally and like this
is the most them thing ever
they're like just funniest couple and
they're just like so normal
yeah and it's like that's like that's
what I hope a celebrity would you like
you're both in Vegas you need to get
married in the u.s. let's go to the
chapel Dan and chasing speechless down
the aisle that was live streaming and we
have a wedding no I was obsessed that
and I've been obsessing them for so long
but like I really and I say this with
the utmost genuine feelings like I wish
them a lifetime of happy that's like I
love them so much they seem so happy
together like I hope their careers
continue to just rise and rise like
they're both at their peaks I hope it
just keeps going and I just love them so
much and they're always nice to me so
like I really love them ya know I love
them so much I recently
become like truly obsessing them
especially her and their Instagram and
that's Caesar bunny hop hop hopping into
this way so that boy know she's so funny
and do you know her and that's - yeah I
just love her and honestly I'm not gonna
lie like I'm in J sisters step I'm a
jaysis you're sad and you know what I
read on people the article that you're
trying to load it said you know what
Sophie's married name is gonna be Sophie
Belinda Jonas beautiful beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful angel the set method Jonas
Brothers performance one I love the J
sisters I love Priyanka Nick John I love
Kevin and Danielle Jackie I'm so here
and I love the six of them and they are
the core six and you know what the
performance was stellar and we're gonna
go into all the details but I have to
say finally after years of neglect
justice for Kevin Jonas was what served
it's like they really got their [ __ ]
together in terms of who plays what role
and it's like Nick and Joe are
definitely the hard drive to lead men
the heartthrobs yeah but I'm talking
about an actual banjo huh
they both today both the number one a
guy this group and they were few CS the
question yeah one stands in the middle
with the other one stinks it's like
they've really and I really in my true
soul belief like that was the cause of
the breakup it's like Joe was just this
the frontman regardless and kick was not
okay with it but it left this space for
like what does Kevin do and like Kevin
used to sing and I do think that Kevin
does a lot on the back end like in terms
of writing songs and like writing music
I think I want to think but they finally
and the when I'm out singing singing
gels and then they keep by the ocean I'm
like this epic but how does Kevin fit
how does Kevin fit and then they had
Kevin we did the jar and the pyro and I
was like yes and that's what jerk ours
Jurek harness that's what was meant to
be for Kevin Jonas and they all finally
found their stride
I was happy he was given this moment of
respect this rock star moment like I was
[ __ ] here for it's like whether or
not he is like the musical one in the
group at least now like that would be
the way to make it all make sense it's
like you know Kevin's the behind the
scenes man he writes the music he's
playing he's you know strumming that
guitar and so whether or not that's true
at least like let us think that it is so
that everyone feels like equal and Kevin
was he was looking at yeah they were all
lookin [ __ ] jerk Aras know that AJ
sisters knowing the words to the song
obviously but especially that one part
and Donna did do it
so confusing okay oh the says I've been
stumbling on top because it's jumbled
and out of buzz and it's that song is so
good it's so good I'm looking the Jonas
Brothers on tour for sure oh yeah they
just announced their tour that's the
square room I'm just so excited for them
this is really like you would think six
years ago it was like the prime of their
life you know screaming fans Hannah
Montana opening how do they think it
could that doesn't get bigger than
opening for Hannah Montana sophie turner
sophie turner your cars and i was
thinking it's like they're so crazy in
war shows about seating like most people
don't even get a plus-one just cause
like there's so many celebrities and
this the jonas sisters whatever they
took up six seats which is a lot but
each individually brings so much and
then I was thinking [ __ ] BTS took up
seven front row seats and literally I
couldn't pick any of them out of a
lineup little but like the the awards
show system just like throws BT I set
all of their problems they have a class
instance Joe strategically so that in
the background you can see the BTS
people and the kids scream totally
one two three oh my god I got eight I've
never been to an award show before and I
like I knew that there's a thing called
seat fillers and I just I'm so Jackie
I'm so nice to assume that it was just
like this orderly organized you know
really just like respectful everyone
tells you like it's all seat fillers
it's like no I thought when someone goes
to the bathroom you know a seat fillers
slide and they're escorted by a man in
the Tipsy no to the seat and the second
they get up they move them yeah and like
it's really only one beep who go to
another but it's like one or two people
at a time you guys it was pandemonium
like I don't even know if that's the
right word it was mayhem like literally
every commercial break
35,000 people in ball gowns running to
get a seat they're all BTS fans they
were so cute they were so excited they
were so dressed I've been like they
deserve those front row seats yeah it
was it was a doggy it was a seat-filler
eat seat-filler world out there the
second we went to commercial break we
were done we couldn't get up we had
seats and you could get up a seat-filler
chicken it was a seat each seat world it
was so crazy c-pillar I imagine you
don't know if you're filling the back
room or the front row so watching the
schools come up to enemies all girls I
can't even say girls and guys no sorrows
and it was
I'll be teaming come up and realizing
how close to the front they're getting
like it was just so excited was pure joy
also like they're gonna elbow the [ __ ]
out of anyone Jackie went up to get
snacks and I literally every 10 seconds
it was an ass on I see it I'm like sorry
someone sitting here is like we had
seats like tickets literally it's a seat
eight seat world no one told us today
they tell you that it was wild
back to the Jonas Brothers I was so
happy for all of those BTS fans whose
dreams came true and like those seat
fillers are the ones who are cheering
like China crazy the sound fillers verse
verse the world was the Battle of
Winterfell Oh totally yet and then we
just yeah literally
it was it was hilarious okay what else
happened at the Billboard Music Awards
just the Jonas Brothers killing it did
you halsy oh yeah she was um like really
tucked in the back of her set so like
literally no but that one was really
made for TV I couldn't say anything yes
but she sounded good but then like
Khalid was on our side so and he was lit
he was dancing he's like such a cutie
yeah I don't really know his music and I
didn't know one song he performed he was
dancing and I'm like cutie he was also
at the wedding I believe yes he was
Danny che was at the wedding Diplo was
at the wedding
Khaled was at the wedding it seemed like
was it come one come on say to Priyanka
Nick obviously I don't know if Danielle
and Kevin were like I didn't see them
but I just assumed that they were also
it's like so crazy mix spent probably
fifteen million dollars on his wedding
and like the two truly up station yeah
no but there and they will upstage again
they're gonna spend like a decent amount
money and I think that this wedding is
bigger and better than whatever they're
their European wedding will be you know
I can't help think about this possible
thing that they could have done you know
what I can't help but think about what
the the life of Danielle Jonas
she's just from New Jersey like I think
she wants in her slot like she this is a
regular girl know when it's like she has
all of the perks but I don't have the
neg continues to like have her old like
too but it's like oh I guess I'll hop on
a private plane and go to the Bibi rice
and go to the wedding of the century
should then also like just you know pick
up the kids from day school right but
it's like oh do we want to do a reality
show again I don't know that's what I'm
sorry to say I think now more than ever
we need to bring back married to Jonas
they could have truly like the biggest
maybe even as big as Kardashian's like
the biggest reality show yeah if it was
about the three of them but then also I
mean Joe and Sansa are interesting and
funny so like they
probably carry the show but if they
aren't interesting or funny like it
wouldn't be a good show so yeah it's a
lot of pressure no if they all really
gave it their all Mike wanted to have
the biggest reality show and like have
ten years on TV I think they could do it
yeah if they started right now yeah I'm
going on tour I'm interested to know
like I mean now Sansar her time on Game
of Thrones is over like is she gonna go
on tour with them probably oh my god she
would be like great on tour yeah how the
logistics work right that looks late I
don't know if Priyanka can necessarily
go on tour she is like a booming career
I think actually tour is great through
Priyanka cuz she's really a woman of the
world you know so it makes sense for her
to be like travel traveling the world
yeah and I feel like they do tour
glamorous like they don't like they're
not on a bus they're on a jet oh for
sure
that's like the level I need to get to
agreed I'd one more thing to say about
three VMAs but probably won't remember
and I'm sure it'll come back to me but
yeah what a weekend no it really was a
wild week it was if you didn't catch our
podcast episodes all throughout this
week make sure to check them out we
recapped stagecoach from each country
caps Game of Thrones we also did a
bomb-ass stagecoach blog on patreon so
it's patreon.com slash morning shows we
got five new episodes coming out yet
this month I what I was gonna say is
Monday is the Met Gala
oh and just making Bianca always remind
me of the Met Gala cuz that's where they
first like petal came in relationship
and I didn't believe it and hopefully
like Joe and so if you'll be there and
I'm actually excited push into a patreon
like mikelis extravaganza yeah yes and
we can really get into every like well G
was a slight recap on this show but um
so we can get into like every every year
and then let's read the blind oh let's
read the blinds yeah that's a good idea
that's a good idea let's write that on
Monday okay next on Monday which is also
the day of my big announce in which I'm
like not that I'm not trying to keep so
you know under wraps I want people to
know it's just like it's a big
announcement you know have a lot of
cities yeah it's the final are you going
on tour it's the final it's a simulcast
it's the final
down no way it's the final captain I
can't say the word caftan without
thinking of well yeah when the Real
Housewives of New York went to Morocco
on probably like one of the most
underrated Housewives trips ever wear
any well south yes
LuAnn falls off and she all she says is
yeah Hubley oh my god I love her
okay next story Blake Lively and Ryan
Reynolds are expecting their third child
together
what does headline should say is Ryan
Reynolds like Blake Lively out of her
cage long enough to everyone she's
pregnant
Blake glad they showed up to a movie
premiere in Manhattan on Thursday
showing off a baby bump on the red
carpet next to her husband Ryan Reynolds
the former Gossip Girl star who voices a
character in pokemon detective Pikachu
oh I didn't know that revealed the bump
while donning retrofits Rebecca dress
according to E news oh my god she wore
retro feet
I wore a trophy are you Blake Lively are
you pregnant with their third child no
just a food baby Congrats to our very
own pokey mum at Lake Lively so happy
for you and Anthony Bridals the Twitter
account for Reynolds movie shared I just
need so crazy that she was able to keep
this under wraps like nobody can keep
anything secret anymore yeah I guess we
haven't seen her in a bit cuz she was in
her cage so there's a movie out right
but now we'll be seeing her every day
morning if she's in the movie or he is
it sounds like she voiced the movie
what's this movie Pokemon detective
Pikachu oh yeah they sponsored me on
Carnival yeah so they're pretty in tune
honestly I feel like when you're at the
celebrity level of doing voiceovers on
like cartoons like that's really where
the money's at like cause didn't ever
have to work another day in her life
she's in every [ __ ] animated cartoon
[ __ ] movie no totally Kevin Hart -
also Kelly Clarkson she's in ugly dolls
she always court in okay I'm gonna
sneeze if we could just mute me
I'll meet me - hold on everyone I'm
gonna blow
really how good does that feel great
really happy for you know that I am um
what else I am actually very much
looking forward to Blake Lively's um
like pregnancy style but when she does
step out of her house she always does so
very glamorous Lee but she also says she
doesn't have a stylist and I'm just
gonna say I don't believe that I don't
believe that either like it's too good I
definitely think that she enjoys
dressing herself like here and there but
like when she's wearing pants suit after
pants I couldn't agree more
it's like that's not that wasn't your
idea and like I'm with a tiny purse like
you can't even fit a credit card in like
where do you put your simpered where do
you put your semper that's the thing
with tiny purses is you know they're not
conducive for anything except severed
right that's why on a night out on the
town you don't have smelly bits said
bird maybe Sandberg was alone behind the
tiny purse trend maybe sin bird is a
luxury fragrance subscription service
for perfumes and colognes a way for you
to to discover new perfumes without
buying an entire bottle more than four
hundred and fifty designer brands for
you to choose from Prada
Tom Ford versus Dolce & Gabbana you
choose the perfume you want and they'll
send you a 30-day supply that's 120
sprays enough to apply more than four
times daily for a month if you're not
sure what type of scent you're looking
for you can sort and find your fragrance
by brand style occasion or season and
with our exclusive offer you can get 50%
off your first month today that's only
seven dollars and fifty cents for your
first fragrance go to semper calm /
toast use our code toast for 50% off
your first month that's scent bird scen
tird comm / toast and use code toast for
just seven dollars and fifty cents for
your first perfume or cologne sign on
smell amazing
mmm okay next story is one that you
requested oh my god
yeah Teen Mom star Jenelle Evans husband
under investigation for animal cruelty
despite first calling off an
investigation police in Jenelle Evans
and David Easton's North Carolina's
hometown are now looking into
allegations of animal cruelty after the
Teen Mom stars husband admitting to
killing her dog on Instagram quote
Columbus County sheriff's office in
Columbus County Animal Control initiated
a joint investigation into the
nations are up told page six in the
press release on Thursday on Wednesday
Columbus County Sheriff's Office told
page six that officers conducted a
welfare check at Easton's home on Monday
night and since all humans in the
household were fine they found no
evidence to substantiate a further
investigation however it appears that
after receiving pressure from the public
who were outraged at the killing of
Evans's french bulldog police decided to
look into matters further Eason
confessed on Tuesday to shooting Evans
dog nugget after the animal allegedly
snapped at his two-year-old daughter
enslie liar I don't believe that were a
[ __ ] second I don't give a damn what
animal bites my baby on the face whether
it be your dog or mine the dog is a dog
I don't put up with that [ __ ] at all he
captioned the clip of the dog on
Instagram I'm all about protecting my
family it is my life's mission some
people are worth killing or dying for
and my family means that much to me oh
my god I hate him so much this story
gives me the biggest Pitt and your owner
who I blame MTV shame on you for making
these morons famous seriously first the
girl Thera who's still in a sex tape
with her daughter in the room you know
like these people are disgusting and I'm
really like this is really upsetting and
I'm not here for it I don't think that
that dog bit the kid I'm telling you
just think he's hot I just think he
looks like a [ __ ] crazy person who
has a gun and just like wants to shoot
things you say you think you shot him at
a thousand percent I'm so upset by this
and I just want to say let's say the dog
came for the good there's like four
thousand things you can do before you
shoot it okay like okay take it to a
shelter leave it on the side of the road
you're a big man you're bigger than the
dog just pull the dog off no it's so
stupid and if you really did want to get
rid of the dog like here's a perfect
example but this dog is on baby aren't
you an inch away from shooting your baby
no and it's like how come you just have
like guns in your house with your dogs
and your kids and the whole thing is so
weird and like here's what here's the
first perfect example the biermann's and
first of all their dog was like a tiny
little puppy remember if the biermann's
huge dogs in that [ __ ] I ate the face
of one of the Beermen kids they handled
it so perfectly
Kim was like get rid of the dogs get rid
of the dog the dog was wet for a while
to the trainer's house and they were
thinking do we bring the dog back to
what do we do and while I didn't
necessarily agree with their decision to
bring the dog back into the house as a
pet um they brought it back like with
the new trainer
with the new crate like they took all
the necessary precautions and as far as
I know it's fine
well that is not what I would have
necessarily done I respect the decision
to moving forward in a
meaningful way there's 1,000 things you
could do before you kill this dog what I
would do I would get rid of the dog
obviously well I say in the act a dog is
mauling your child oh oh do you think he
that's what the vibe I got the dog was
on the kid and and so he shot the dog no
oh my god the dog divide that I got oh
you are a video of the kid does she look
harmed oh I don't know but I thought was
like the dog snapped in a moment and
like almost like and his punishment he
killed but not as punishment just like
they thankfully nothing happened but we
can't have it happen again
oh oh I thought it was a to me this
seemed like a reaction like um like in
the moment dansgame oh my god that's
crazy and i don't think i think there
would be more evidence like the kid
would be like I don't know whatever like
let's say God forbid 1 million times
Theo like I have a baby it's not really
and he'll snap to the baby and like
either he like bit the nose or whatever
like as much as he paints me like I
would obviously have to get rid of Theo
but it would never [ __ ] shoot him I
would either find a home from with like
someone who doesn't have kids take it to
with like a good Shabana from dogs yeah
like there's a million things or like
honest em came to mom like I'm saying it
I'm giving or Ben's parents like maybe
there are so many options before I shoot
the oh okay but this story makes me so
mad at honestly look there is blood on
the hands of MTV and I didn't want
that's why I wanted to say this like
shame on you yeah like the only reason
the only reason that Jenelle Evans has a
big mansion and a dog and guns is
because of the money she makes on MTV
here's the thing I'm always ready to
blame to blame the network however wait
they showed the kids face hold on I have
to I'm so invested in this video people
are saying I want to see cuz I don't
want to speak without Jenelle he took
the dog in the backyard and shot it
right so it wasn't in the moment okay so
that makes it even less not that it was
ever justifiable but that's the worst
thing how I felt her name wrong chin no
her name is here so okay 15 minutes ago
squishy-face nugget I'm crying every day
I love you so much and I'm so sorry
I'm speechless you were my sidekick and
know the moment I felt bad and would
cuddle okay there's nothing here um
where's the kid
six days ago no kid what's her husband's
name
Eason David Eaton EAS o n David Easton
let's see if he know there's nothing
here oh my god these people are freaks
like I'm so I want to see a picture of
apparently shoes tights just had a red
marks like no skin was breached oh here
she's she's combating fake news on her
Instagram story Jenelle Evans husband
was covered in blood after viciously
beating the dog from Yahoo she said
that's fake news I actually do believe
that that's fake news I just think that
he shot the dog but I can't tell you why
but I just have a pin like I know I have
a feeling like there's something weird
here first I mean like there's no there
was no attack and intuition to know
Jenni there was no attack on the kid I'm
telling you whether I don't think it
matters whether there was or there
wasn't there's no ever an excuse to like
take a dog out back and shoot it no I
couldn't what is this like the 50s like
relax
there's literally 250 no totally like
what like there are so many
organizations just like created so
that's something like this doesn't
happen or so that you have a resource
like when something happens like a dog
lashing out it's possible it happens
especially if the dog like has been
through some sort of trauma where it was
abandoned like this happens and it's
terrible but it happens like and there
are so many things to do before you just
take your dog out back and shoot it
horrible MTV there's blood on your hands
and that's all I wanted to say yeah
horrible and people are saying that he
did much more stuff to the dog before
shooting it even apparently it's like
really graphic I don't want to know I
don't want to know okay
shame on these people seriously like I'm
listing the horrible story if I ever run
into Jenelle Evans on her husband which
might happen like I'm taking it up then
not back no but also it's I don't know
if they're still on TV but like they are
they are I'm like 90% sure grounds for
dismissal I couldn't agree more but like
I think to get fired born here the
craziest thing Farrah Abraham who was
like awful she didn't get fired she quit
like that's the low how low the bar is
for MTV I don't know what you would have
to do to get fired from Teen Mom yeah I
yeah it's just a cycle I guess cuz you
get famous for being stupid they can do
stupid things and it's like we're not
supposed to be upset it's like that's
why we made you famous right
interesting I just feel really good
about the fact that I had no part in
making Jenelle Evans famous like I never
watched I just enjoy him and she was on
the cover of Starr mags so awful
okay fade them final story update from a
story earlier this week which I'm just
so shocked by I just can't believe in
2019 after 2018 this is happening
Woodstock 50 is being plagued by cold
feet
the organizer of Woodstock 50 says the
show will go on
oh god now it's really gonna be fire
festival vibes music sources told page
six that reps for the act involved are
getting cold fleet feet obviously
festival's financial banker Dentsu aegis
network said this week that the August
concert was off yes this morning to us
reported it so now we look stupid again
yeah Woodstock founder Michael Lane told
us on Thursday that he's confident the
show can survive because all the acts
which include jay-z and Miley Cyrus have
been paid wait I'm sorry there's an
update on the comments she is still on
the show but he's not allowed to be on
the show because he's made some terrible
homophobic comments oh so it's like
that's how low the bar is for MTV like
okay ready
it's like him he shot the dog when TLC
cancelled mom and Gio - honey boo boo
honey boo boo didn't do anything her mom
was just eating a pedophile yeah but
they canceled the whole show at least
they have a moral compass true makes you
think makes you think sorry continue
that's what stuck a music source griped
no agents want to send their acts
they're arguing the contracts we're with
that financial bankers and they're gone
no one wants to be a part of this if
it's going to go down in flames duh they
insisted all the contracts were paid
were made through both entities there is
no reason for them not to play I guess
if they've already been paid like they
have to come but why would they already
have been paid for something that's
going down in August so you hear like
50% before no but I guess if it's for
like something new in order to secure
like that Miley Cyrus comes like you
have to pay her yeah
jay-z he also said that he's in talks
with new backers I think once it gets
turned around everyone will be able to
relax I mean I just don't know how you
come like if there's any especially if
it's possible if there's any like
inkling of firing vibes like why would
anyone go participate to get older
person or ticket to holder like if it's
an upstate New York I don't know what
like the accommodations are up there you
know how many hotel options there are
but why would like don't just stay home
and watch her on watch the Miley Cyrus
had Montana best of both worlds DVD ever
since fire festival I feel like it's now
even
ten times harder to get a new festival
off the ground like to get people to buy
tickets to an unknown vessel to get Acts
to agree to an unknown festival like
they really Billy McFarland we're in the
entire festival industry like the only
ones that stand the test of time now are
like stagecoach and Coachella no or I
think I think it's a good thing though
because really festivals require people
so much money from people so much time
so much trust in faith and like it's
festivals just kept continuing to pop up
and like even if they were like low-key
scams where it's like okay the festival
went off but like we stayed in a tent
and we paid for a bill alike I'm glad
that it's it's been ruined for everyone
you know it's like either go big or stay
home and for me it's always stay home
yeah even though like wouldn't think
about it fire festival is like kind of a
great idea yeah that's why so many
people bought tickets yeah someone
should do it golden voice like you have
a level where can you act like Exuma was
not the place for it
no but there's definitely a place for it
what about the Florida Keys or what
about like Atlantis oh yeah totally I
guess but like there's so much
infrastructure on Atlantis would feel
like your own Atlantis like it needs to
be a quiet island we're all there is
this festival yeah actually says who do
whatever
yeah Beach Florida Keys is a good idea
Oh Tortuga yeah yeah the keys I feel
like there's always an extra key laying
around not always oh my god cheap the
hotel key okay those are the five story
what is yeah breelan
what else anything else you wanted to
chat about on this Friday apparently
morning I haven't watched your houses in
New York but I should say been not and
not been hearing good things really I
didn't watch the circus episode did you
no no I've just been hearing like a not
great things but also it's really the
beginning so like I always give a season
as an amount of time it's not that's
been on for a while now it has it's been
maybe two months we should be in it did
you see the video of the OC ladies in
Florida like yelling at each other at
the hotel like Tamara being so Tamara
you know what like whenever I see videos
of like toasters boots on the ground
like finding videos like when we saw the
videos of the Beverly Hills ladies
fighting in the Bahamas last year
something about it is like really
letdown because you just like when
you're watching it on TV you just like
think of it as like this mystical
fairyland where like grown women fight
but then and when you see it in real
life it's like kind of sad yeah except I
felt that way when I saw the Beverly
Hills fighting in
it's like these are like it was just so
weird it was like station I wonder why
if I'm fighting in a restaurant but I
said when I saw it tamara like yelling
at someone so Charlie dog I literally
felt like I was watching the episode
yeah like it was so real I'm actually
like ready for OC I always like miss the
franchise that's not on at the moment we
literally said the exact opposite thing
oh [ __ ]
we're like when it's not on I don't give
a [ __ ] oh that's true you're like I can
go without it it depends on actually
that's true I'm seeing that episode made
me more excited and they're also in
Miami celebrating Shannon's divorce
which we talked about and Vicki's
engagement oh it actually is Vicki
confirmed to be full-time cast mate or
kind of I had heard she was friend of oh
I have no idea I feel like she's
full-time because like radar Online did
a tweet like that Vicki's could be fired
and she was like she responded to eight
she was like we're still negotiating and
Kelly Dodd responded she was like we
already started filming oh so I don't
know
interesting that'll be interesting also
um there was a picture of Tamra and
Shannon Shannon looks amazing by the way
and I'm just so excited for like I love
chef Shannon three-point oh yeah and
Tamra like at do you see pictures of her
in a bikini
she's literally looks 21 did you see
Shannon no Tamra the house that she
moved into this season she already moved
out of I did there's a weird house is
weird and she like wasn't that jazzed
about it and I liked that house that I
live with the booth in the kitchen was
like my show booth yeah oh my by the way
we saw Sean booth at its 11:11 make a
wish honestly I wish for Sean booth we
saw some booth at Coachella stage stage
he's just looking ripped and hot as [ __ ]
yeah Sean booth was looking fine tonight
honestly you know who's looking fine
tonight Sean Muffet Moscow ski yeah I
love Sean I know yeah yes so she already
moved out of that house
Shh weirdness weirdness I just feel like
houses are such a personal thing and
like either you take to it or like you
don't and they have yelled that house
Richard it's like she's still trying to
take to her new house but I have to say
I absolutely love her new house like
just aesthetically
no sane but it's like she had such good
juju in the last house did you see that
Kyle Richards she's traveling somewhere
and she went home goods and she did her
story like don't tell Faye Resnick oh my
god I think it's her designer bird home
goods can get it have you been - I'm
good - feel like about Matt I don't know
there's only one in the city and it's
like on like 99 Columbus and so I know
you've never been there no but it's such
a great store for your new apartment you
might consider taking a trip uptown
I might okay well I don't want to sneeze
again on this show are you okay yeah
it's just like I've been holding in so
many so much snot that it's not making
its way to my eyes oh okay well so
here's the thing you guys the thing is
is that it's Friday and where's what's
gonna happen I'm heading to Baltimore
tonight and Silver Spring tomorrow
there's still tickets left in Silver
Spring but when I return on Monday it is
big announcement I'm at 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time I'll tell you what the
announcements but I probably already
told you I'm hitting up all the city's
women hit up and then I'm ending it in
the most epic way ever like I can't even
talk about it so that'll be on Monday
and you'll be able to get tickets if
you're a patreon subscribers so the WWE
Tron comm forward slash the morning
shows if you want to get tickets to
Toronto LA San Diego and if they sell
out like that's not my problem so you
might want to consider becoming a
patreon before Monday and then Tuesday
is it Tuesday yeah - I'm working on
something that I told you I've pretty
much told you all - as well um hopefully
I have some news for you next week
it's exciting time it is an exciting
time because it's also Friday so
everyone have an amazing weekend drink a
lot don't drink and drive and just relax
get back to your roots and we'll see you
on Monday okay nice bye
you